few years ago this was all Farmland sure
on a city of almost 2 000 square
kilometers was built from scratch in
just six years
is one of tens of thousands of people
whose homes and Villages were demolished
to make way for the project
we were farmers for Generations but now
we live in these high-rise apartments
and I'm very happy
authorities did not allow Al Jazeera to
speak to any other residents but were
Keen to Showcase its state-of-the-art
facilities this is one of shong-un's
smart buses that driverless and electric
buses are undergoing trials and will
eventually be free for the public to use
they can drive for up to 200 kilometers
before needing to be charged
the buses have sensors that react to
traffic pedestrians and bad weather with
a detection range of almost 250 meters
was built to ease some of the congestion
in Beijing home to more than 20 million
people independent Urban Design experts
liken it to an experiment testing
solutions to the problems many Chinese
cities face
is carrying a lot of you know best
talents from different disciplines from
different parts of the country to
design this you know
new solution for the whole countries
as China's birth rate declines zhongan
is designed to attract would-be parents
a lot of people in major cities decide
not to have chosen because it just had
too hard to for you know their future
children to get into good schools so
Xiang is trying to you know overcome
problems like this so it has been a very
child focused Urban Design
whose children used to have informal
lessons in their Village enrolling them
in school has opened up new
opportunities
I hear many universities will move here
from Beijing I would be so happy if my
children could study these universities
it's unclear how much the government
will spend on completing which is
supposed to have almost 3 million
residents within the next 10 years but
it's likely to be one of its most costly
development projects with no expense
spared on what could be the blueprint
for China's future cities Jessica
Washington Al Jazeera shong-un China
the head of the World Health
Organization has